dwayne haskins is sounding pretty good
right now for the la rams however not
that they could get him on board by
sunday because the covet 19 protocols
would suggest that he wouldn't be able
to show up until just about time for
kickoff but even then dwayne haskins may
be a better option than john walford
from wake forest all due respect to john
walford from wake forest he was an aaf
superstar
if there were any he
has never thrown a regular season passed
in the nfl he will be the quarterback if
jared goff can't play on sunday and goff
has the dislocated thumb we confirmed
last night that there is a fracture he's
being evaluated by dr stephen shin kind
of strange that a guy named shin would
be a thumb guy but that's a different
story altogether shin treated brees last
year for his thumb issue that knocked
him out for five weeks the question is
what can goff do
can he before stall surgery he'll have
surgery after the season he wants to
play through it yada yada we'll see what
happens but without jared goff
i think the rams are in trouble although
although i've already seen the ground
swell
from that that
pro sean mcvay media click
where they're already saying well you
know it is mcveigh and this walford guy
hey he kind of likes him he wouldn't be
on the team if he didn't like him and
maybe this is a chance for mcveigh to
show that he can do it with other
quarterbacks good prove it and then it
shows how wrong it was for you to have
jared goffstein do a contract that pays
him 33.5 million a year sharing
yeah that's exactly right mike and
all i know is the games they've lost
golf has made really big mistakes that
that have cost them and you know maybe
john wilford comes in and doesn't make
those mistakes but he's certainly not
going to make those big plays either
this is a lot to ask for
a guy who's never played in the nfl but
i don't know what you do with golf after
this i don't expect him to play sunday i
don't know how you play with the a
broken thumb i just don't see that
happening if you could play with the
broken thumb maybe the breaks in a
different point but i would have thought
that drew brees would have been the guy
to play through that and he he couldn't
play through it so you know we'll see
what the second opinion says about
certain we know he needs surgery but
when he needs surgery and if he needs it
now he's he's out for the year
but goff's future very much is in doubt
and this is a big chance now for john
wilford if he gets to play to come in
and maybe prove that he can be the guy
next year for the rams
my guess would be and i've yet to crunch
the numbers and assess the cap charges
and the other consequences the rams
presumably in the same type of
predicament that the eagles are with
carson wentz still too early in the deal
to do anything about the contract too
expensive to trade him no one's going to
want him and it is amazing to me
2015. i made this point last night on
twitter 2015
jameis winston marcus mariota picks one
and two their teams resisted signing
them to long-term deals they each got
their full five years four years of
their base contract plus a gigantic it
was like 20 and a half million dollar
fifth year option payment and they
walked away as free agents
one year later goff at one
wence at two
they both get second contracts after
three years and with wentz i get it
because wence played really well he was
an mvp candidate in 2017 and then he's
just lost it it's unprecedented that an
nfl quarterback you assume okay you put
him in the category of franchise guy
that he just loses it with goff and i
remember saying
summer of 2019
why are they going to pay golf yeah he
took him to a super bowl but sean
mcvay's the reason it's not golf they
could find somebody else to do what goff
does maybe they'll be the team that says
no thanks we're not going to pay you and
a bunch of these jared goff rams fans
went nuts and the next thing you know
the rams signed him it's like what are
you doing
you know i said this earlier today that
if uh
sorry about that that that if um
you you would put 33 and a half million
on the table and say either jared goff
or sean mcveigh get it
jared goff is not the guy i'm giving it
to i'm giving it to sean mcvay
yeah no question mike and and let's go
one step further in that draft the team
that should have signed the quarterback
to a long-term deal after the third year
was the cowboys with dak prescott and
they didn't and
that that contract was then compared to
what goff and what wentz got the cowboys
said we're not paying that and now they
are where they are so you had three
teams completely screw up the contracts
of the quarterbacks from that draft that
year it's just amazing to me that it
worked out like that for those three
teams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports